I'm back guys ghs is back now first of
all I'd like to say thank you so much
for keeping faith me and my channel I
was away for a while and a lot of
comments on my facebook as well as my
channel saying that are you dead why you
are not uploading any more videos and
one harsh comment was like if you don't
upload any more videos then I'm going to
kill you well I know there are a lot of
fans of my channel out there and they
want me to put videos regularly and that
I should do but trust me guys I have a
reason and after showing you this reason
you are going to believe me
the reason is on November 7th 2015 I
become the father of an angel and as a
dad I have a lot of responsibilities and
from last six months I was giving my
precious time to my daughter and that's
why I was not uploading any more videos
many of you knows that I'm not a full
time chess player so I have another job
so it's very hard for me do you know
cope up with this all things but anyways
whatever happens was the past now let's
talk about something good something
which you are waiting for and trust me
guys next six months you are going to be
delighted let me tell you some good news
number one from the month of July at
least up till December you are getting
at least two videos per month so that
means I am going to be very active in
terms of YouTube uploading and you will
see my frequent update number two my
website is almost done so by the end of
the July you are going to see my own
website where you can find my all videos
and not only that I am planning for a
Premium Membership on that website where
I have covered some amazing tricks which
you can actually use in officially
federating tournament yes that's right
so you can use this
tricks infuriating tournaments and the
cost is very less and even though people
who don't want to become a premium
member of my website those contains will
be released later on on my youtube
channel so it's not like you are going
to miss out something number three I'm
going to give you the list of dirty
chess tricks as well as my premium
videos so you have a very good idea what
I am up to ok guys so here is the list
of dirty chess tricks now the most
important part which you don't want to
miss out that is dirty chest tricks
16 17 and 18 where I have covered my own
trickiest recruit against French let me
tell you this Roberta give me great
success online like I almost power ratio
of 80% winning chances in these three
dirty chests recap resource I have
covered many tricks and also provides
the resources where you can learn this
hopefully graph truth audience French so
please don't miss out that after that
I'm going to show you how to completely
diffuse the opening called sniper there
are a lot of modern players who are
actually dealing with this sniper mordor
but after watching my 30 Cheswick video
you know exactly how to deal with almost
all the variations in the 20th path I'm
going to look at one amazing shocking
line against Evans gambit which not many
ones gambit player are ready and as a
black you get a great advantage at this
point I would also like to mention my
upcoming premium videos the number one
is no teacher 618 where I have covered
the main line which you are most likely
to be faced when you are playing a
hiring component and the line which I
have recommended is very tricky one
it has my 10 to 15 moves depth and the
amazing part is there are hardly any
games played in database the second one
is one of my favorite that is a very hot
novelty against Philidor personally I
have gone through 5 videos and 10 books
and none of them mention the line which
I have suggested against rate so you
better watch out for that the
last but not least recently I found out
a very cunning line against Sicilian
thigh mano and in just recent years many
top players are using as a stock weapon
and it has a tremendous success ratio so
if you are a full player then this is a
must weapon for you I hope with this
brief update just like me you are going
to be very enthusiastic about my next
upcoming videos feel free to post your
comments and suggestions and I'll meet
you very soon bye aunt again but now
comes the another dazzling moon that is
night cactus d-file
and black position is completely wrong
and that move is Bishop to b5 BAM so
forget about the rock now that Venus
trap